[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah!
Google I/O, 2016, right?
Oh, come on.
We're done clapping now?
Is that it?
[LAUGHTER]
All right, we're done.
Hello, everyone.
How are you doing today?
Good?
Staying out of the sun?
Yes?
Fantastic.
Hey, I want to thank
everybody for being here.
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and I've got to tell you,
I love Google I/O. I love Google
I/O, because this is the one
time during the whole year
that the crazy Googlers get
to talk to all of you all
about the weird stuff we
do that we can't talk
about the rest of the year.
And that is fantastic, right?
And today, we're
talking about something
that's so near and
dear to my heart,
and that's data compression.
It is, by far, one of my
favorite, most obsessive things
that I ever get involved with.
And I'm so happy that
all of you are here.
And all the people standing
outside-- I'm sorry.
There's capacity issues.
We'll give them a t-shirt
or something later.
But really quick, before we
begin, I've got to tell you,
we've only got 45 minutes today.
And that is just not
enough time to get
through all the awesome, crazy
image compression content
that we need to get done.
So over the past
couple of weeks,
I've been trying to
diffuse some of this stuff
to some other places.
First off, here's
my Medium.com page.
Has anyone been
reading these articles?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]!
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah!
A round of applause if you've
been reading the Medium
articles, yeah?
[APPLAUSE]
We're live, folks. you've
got to make 'em hear it.
Yeah?
If you read these articles,
we get into a lot more depth
on how some of these
image formats work
and how to make
them a lot smaller.
Second off, of course, is the
Android Performance Patterns
videos.
Anybody watch these?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
That's fantastic.
Now, if you've ever been
interested in data compression,
if you've ever tried
to make an attempt
to understand the
algorithms, but found
that the math is
really weird, or it's
too gnarly of a
concept, or maybe
it's not presented
in the right way,
then good news for you,
because Alex Hackey
and I have actually
got together,
and we've actually written
a data compression book.
And we took a different
approach to it.
We threw out all the math.
All of that crazy gnarly stuff
that makes your brain melt,
we got rid of it.
And we re-approached
how we should
be teaching data compression
to modern developers
and engineers.
So if you're interested in a
deep, fundamental understanding
of how to make your apps smaller
for users, check out this book.
Deal?
All right, business
is out of the way.
Let's get started.
So when we talk about
reducing the data
sizes of your applications
for your users,
there's generally two buckets
that I like to think of.
On one side, is your APK size.
And this includes
all of the stuff
like code sizes, language
information resources, image
resources.
We've got layout data,
config, blah, blah,
blah-- all of the
information that's
zipped up into a single APK
file and downloaded when
users install your application.
Now, on the other side of
things is all of the other stuff
that your app downloads
once it's installed
from the internet, right?
So this could be many,
many, many things,
but it mostly boils down to
images and serialized data.
Now, I've got to say that
the APK stuff, making
your APKs smaller, is a
whole deep and crazy domain
that we're not going
to get into today.
However, if you
stay in your seats,
the next session will go very,
very deep into that subject.
So make sure you
stick around for that.
One thing you
notice here, though,
is that images actually show
up in both of these categories.
And that's why we're
focusing on our images today.
Because quite frankly,
images are awesome, right?
Round of applause for images?
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah?
I promise you, I will ask you
to applaud weirder and weirder
stuff as the talk goes on,
like who likes gummy bears?
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, there we go.
We have to have an understanding
as an audience and a presenter.
That's how this works, right?
Images are fantastic.
We use them in our applications.
We convey emotion, and
power, and information,
and all this other great stuff.
But images also have a problem,
is that they're easy to bloat.
They're easy to get
too big, and too many
resolutions, and
too many pixels.
And that causes
problems for your users,
because bigger
images take longer
to download, which
means that there's
more bits on the wire, which
costs your users more money
to download them, because
they're on metered plans.
And their cellular
radio is on longer,
downloading the larger
images, so you're
eating their battery more.
All of these little
things add up
when you start bringing
these images down,
which is why making sure that
your images are compressed
as good and as small as possible
is super important to make sure
that your users are having
the best experience.
And in general, there's
a lot of different things
you could do with images.
But as Android developers,
there's really only four data
formats we care about--
PNGs, VectorDrawables, JPEGs
and WebP.
Now, the rest of the talk that
we're going to go into today
is going to be opening up
each one of these formats,
taking a look at how
it works internally
and how you can squeeze
out every bit of data
from these things possible.
Sound good?
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
Don't worry, you'll will get
the hang of the applause cues.
They took down the sign
that I asked for later.
That's OK.
All right.
So let's start at the
top with PNG files.
PNGs have to be one of the
most amazing formats in terms
of Android development.
They've been here as
long as anybody has seen.
They provide amazing quality
and, actually, pretty good
data compression.
So let's figure out what's
going on under the hood.
So let's say we have an image.
The way PNG compression
works is that we
take every row of pixels in
that image, one at a time,
we process each
row individually.
And what we do is,
we apply something
called a filter to it.
Now, the filter itself is
basically a modified delta
processor, right?
So basically, it's going to try
to subtract the current pixel
in the row from the previous
pixels, or the one above it,
and do all this weird math.
The point of the
filter is simple.
It wants to produce the
most number of zeros
and duplicate values possible.
That's it.
That's all it wants to do.
The output of that is then
fed into a very common,
super-everywhere encoding
system called, deflate.
Anybody familiar with deflate?
[ONE PERSON APPLAUDS]
Get him a t-shirt.
[LAUGHTER]
That's all right.
We'll get it to you later.
[LAUGHTER]
Deflate is actually comprised
of two main compression
algorithms.
The first one is called LZ77.
If you've watched my
compressor head video,
then you'll know that LZ77 is
a dictionary algorithm that
tries to match runs of
duplicate characters
multiple times in
a stream of data.
The output of that is then
tossed to a Huffman encoder,
which is a statistical encoder.
If you've ever been
to CS-101, you've
probably dealt with
Huffman in some form.
Now this, again, is
done on a single line.
And the output of deflate
is then kicked out to disk.
Now what these two stages
mean is very important.
In areas of your image where
there's very similar pixels,
or there's a lot of
duplicate pixels,
that filtering stage is going
to produce a lot of zeros.
It's going to produce a lot
of duplicate symbols, which
means the lZ77 and
the deflate stage
are going to come through
and basically make
that stuff disappear.
So areas of similarity are
going to get great compression.
However, areas of
noise, where there's not
a lot of similar pixels, where
there's different colors that
may not be adjoined
to each other,
are actually going to
have worse compression.
And that's what you get with
this trade-off of the filtering
stage with the
deflate stage, right?
Now, with this in
mind, we can obviously
see a couple of places
that PNGs can be optimized
a little bit more, right?
The first, of course,
is less input colors.
If we've got less input colors
coming into the filtering
stage, that means
that we're going
to have less unique
colors coming out,
and we're going to get
better compression.
The other thing is
actually smarter filtering.
I won't get into it right now.
There's a different post on it.
But there's like five
different filtering modes
that the encoder can choose
on and all that other stuff.
And there's a lot of
math and accelerations
that go into finding
that in a way
that it's not going to take
10 years to compute it.
The other thing is a
better deflate algorithm.
Now, believe or not, deflate
isn't the best version
of deflate.
There's actually more
modern deflates out there.
And applying those
to the algorithm
actually produces smaller files.
And finally, removing
chunks-- and that's
actually a tricky one that
I'll get to in a minute.
But I know what you're saying,
like, hey, wait a minute,
all of that stuff should
be happening for me, right?
I mean, there's this really
cool tool in the Android tool
chain called, AAPT.
Anybody heard or that?
Round of applause, yeah?
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
I mean, in reality,
this should be
doing all that for you, right?
It should be crunching your
PNGS down as small as possible.
Anyone seen that happen?
Nobody?
Some people?
Someone's asleep already.
One applause.
Get that guy a t-shirt.
[LAUGHTER]
T-shirts for every
clap. [LAUGHS]
So I want to point out that,
while the AAPT tool is there
to actually try to make
your PNG file smaller,
it doesn't do
everything it could.
AAPT tool does three things
specifically, no more, no less.
The first thing it does
is analyze your PNG files
to see whether or not you're
only using grayscale colors.
So for example, if your
red, green, blue channels
are all the same
color, it will actually
make your entire image into a
single, 8-bit alpha channel.
That's it.
Goes right down to gray scale.
The second thing it'll
look for is whether or not
you're actually using
your transparency channel.
If you've got a fully
opaque image that's
not using any
transparency bits, it'll
actually get rid of
that entire channel
and save it out to be smaller.
And the final thing--
and this is the one
that's pretty awesome-- it'll
actually scan your entire image
and determine whether or not
you're using 256 unique colors.
If you're using
256 unique colors,
it'll save your image
in a palleted format,
which basically decreases
the size by some insane
amount, right?
Basically all of the
32-bit per pixel data
gets quantized into a
little table like that
that we call a palette.
And it's replaced with an 8-bit
pointer into that palette.
So instead of 32 bits per
pixel, you're now down 8.
Good savings, right?
So the question
that I have, though,
is that OK, AAPT is really
good, but how good is it?
And the answer that, I had
to open up an application
and take a look at how AAPT
was impacting and affecting
that application, to
see whether or not
it was doing a really
good job, or if there are
some improvements to be made.
So being I/O, I
felt maybe we should
do a callback to last
year's I/O sched application
and see how well AAPT
was doing with that.
So anyone look through
the source code
of the I/O scheduler
application from last year?
Round of applause?
Yeah?
[APPLAUSE]
Good.
Did anyone find the hidden
Easter egg in the source code?
No?
Oh.
Then forget I said anything.
[LAUGHTER]
So when we open up this file,
there's a lot of assets.
Now, there's two
things to compare here.
Of course, first is the
source code files in GitHub,
and then there's the APK
that you can actually
download from the Play
Store, unzip, and take
a look at the assets, right?
So I wanted to look
between these two,
because if AAPT is
doing a great job,
I should see a big change
between those two file sizes,
right?
So I opened up the
file, and I just
picked some random graphic.
This was the one I
happened to look at.
That's a 144 x 140
pixel PNG file.
And that's 6k.
That's huge, right?
Sorry, this is in the
source code repo, right?
Now, when I open up the
APK and take a look at it,
it's actually only 2k, which is
better, but still way too big
for 144 x 144 pixels.
Like that's massively
huge, right?
And so I said, well, hold
on, something's missing here.
Obviously, we've got
some optimization.
Let's figure out
what's going on.
So I opened up this
image in Photoshop,
and I saved it for the web.
There's a difference
between file
save and file save for web.
There's a whole different
process in there.
In that process, I
actually quantized
it to only use 256 colors.
And you can see,
when I did that, we
got about the same
size as was in the APK.
So we can see that, hey,
the AAPT did its job.
It probably quantized this
to an indexed image, right?
But here's the problem.
Take a look at that image.
Does it look like
it's using 256 colors?
No.
So let's crank it
down a little bit.
Here's what 64
colors looks like.
Anybody see a change?
Let's go even more-- 16 colors.
Still don't see a change.
Eight colors, still
don't see a change.
Or if you do, your eyes
are better than mine.
The point here is that we
went from 256 unique colors
down to eight unique
colors and didn't see
a change in visual perception.
The difference in file size
though, was huge, right?
Because we were able to
find a smaller color size.
So let's look at a
different example here.
So this is one of
the big banner images
that you see inside
of the application.
That's 49.5k in the GitHub
repo, and 32k inside of the APK.
So again, there's some smaller
modifications going on here
to the AAPT tool, but still,
let's see if our trick
works here too, right?
So let's actually
down-res it to 32 colors.
This one isn't that good, right?
I mean, you can see some
banding in the gradients there.
You can see that
some of the colors
just aren't looking
as true as you can.
So let's bump that up
to exactly 256 colors.
Here you can't actually see
any visual difference, right?
But notice the difference
in the file size.
This is only 18k, instead
of the 36k, right?
So this image actually
only needed 256 colors,
but maybe the source
image didn't have that.
And this is the problem
with the AAPT tool.
It does a great job of
those exact three things,
and no more than that.
So in the first
case, we had an image
that obviously
needed less colors
and could have been
optimized more.
And in the second
case, we had an image
that had maybe just
over 256 colors
that, if we set it to 256, it
still would have looked fine.
Right?
AAPT does neither
of these for you,
which means that it's
your job, as a developer,
to step past that
and start doing
additional methods to reduce
the size of your PNG files.
So let's take a look,
as I said before,
how easy it is to mess this up.
So you actually just take a 16
pixel x 16 pixel all red PNG
file, File, Save As from
Photoshop, you look at 2k.
That's 64 pixels, that 2k.
The funny thing
right now is everyone
in the room is doing a gut
check about whether or not
their designers are using
File, Save As from Photoshop
to save their PNGs, right?
Right? [CHUCKLES]
When you save it
for web, though, you
end up at 121 bytes,
which is better,
which is obviously better.
That's the thing we want to see.
This is how easy it is
to mess up this problem.
Now, the good news
is, though, that you
don't have to go into
crazy town with trying
to optimize all those
things we talked
about before with the
different stages of PNG.
PNG optimization is an old
problem, old meaning the 90s,
right?
I mean, some of you were
alive in the 90s, right?
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Yeah.
Who wasn't alive in the 90s?
OK.
All right.
Yeah.
Old people.
Nice.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry-- professional people.
Yeah.
The truth is that there is a
plethora, a plethora of tools
out there that have already been
solving this problem for almost
two decades.
You don't got to do the heavy
lifting, just Google it,
and pick any one of these.
Really.
They all do different
stuff, and have
different algorithms,
and different needs,
and different
settings, and whatnot.
But if you just add any one of
these to your existing asset
chain, you're going to
get an immediate reduction
and an immediate
improvement in file size.
Now, that being said,
there are some things
that you can do to make it even
better in terms of file sizes.
And I only mention
these two things
because I'm seeing them
a lot in applications
that I'm opening and
taking a look at.
AKA here's the
things you are all
doing that you need to stop.
So first off is, if you
can, in every single way,
try, try, try to make your
image 256 colors or less.
It's a pretty simple
quantization step.
You just test it.
You take a look at it.
Here is one of
our Google doodles
that we actually put
on our main page here.
You can see, it came down
as 24 bits per pixel.
It wasn't indexed at 197k.
When we exported it at the
index mode, it was only 73k.
Again, visual difference
here, imperceptible.
But the difference in
file size was huge,
just by trying to take into
account hitting that index
mark.
And you can see, the palette
here is actually pretty simple.
I mean, there's
nothing crazy going on.
By the way, that diamond down
there on that white actually
represents the transparent
pixel color for that.
And you can actually
do a bunch of those.
Read the article.
There's more stuff
on that there.
Here's another one.
Can anybody tell me
why one of these images
is 139 and one of these is 214?
AUDIENCE: Alpha channel.
COLT MCANLIS: Alpha channel.
Good.
What about the alpha channel?
AUDIENCE: One of them's white.
COLT MCANLIS: Wait, did
you read the article?
Oh, wait.
Nevermind.
Cheater.
No, I'm kidding. [LAUGHS]
So it's absolutely
right-- alpha channel.
So here's what's happening.
I've seen this quite a bit in
a lot of the files I've opened.
So visually, you can
see that the last frame
is what the user sees here.
But when you open this
thing up and you take a look
at the RGB channels and
the A channels separately,
you can see that
the RGB actually
has a ton of data that gets
masked out by the alpha value.
The end result is the same
visual image to the user.
But to the compressor,
we still have
to compress all
of that RGB data.
The filtering stage still
has to be run on it.
The output of that
still has to be run
through a deflate algorithm.
And because there's a lot
of non-uniform pixels there,
the result is going to be a lot
of bloat in your compressor,
right?
However, if we try to
pre-multiply this stuff
and mask out the
pixels that we know
are never going to
be seen, we end up
with a much smaller file size.
I have been seeing this in
applications popping up lately
a lot more than I'd like to say.
So take a look at this.
Now, one of the final
things I need to point out.
If you're going to
go down this path,
and you're going to add in some
of these awesome pre-processing
tools to your chain and get
it all working with Gradle,
and you're going tell
your designers to not
do that thing I just said,
and try to make indexed files,
you may run into a
really weird issue.
So let's say we've
got this great image.
It's about 216k.
And we actually run
it through Zopfli PNG,
which is a fantastic
open source tool that
is a better deflate algorithm
compressor for PNG files.
And we get it down
to about 185k.
But when you build it, it
actually goes through AAPT,
and it bloats to 201k.
The reason for this
is that the AAPT tool
doesn't know that you've
pre-processed your image.
Right?
Again, it's only checking
for those three things.
And so it's going to
look at your image,
and it's going to try to make
it into A, B, or C format.
And then it's just going
to save it right to disk.
The problem with that,
though, is that you
may have made modifications.
And obviously, your
version is smaller,
and their version may not be.
To get around this
in your application,
you need to specify
the option Gradle,
cruncherEnabled equals False.
This will disable
AAPT optimization
for all of your PNG files that
are coming though your pipe.
Now the problem, though,
is that, once you do this,
it's kind of on you to make
sure that all of your images
are awesome at that point.
Right?
Which you're all going to do?
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Now the back row.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, let's try the
front row again.
[APPLAUSE]
That was good.
I'm sorry, the
front row's winning.
Back row, you want try again?
[APPLAUSE AND WHISTLING]
Oh.
They added whistling.
Come on, front row.
We'll try again later.
All right.
The live stream's
getting antsy. [LAUGHS]
All right.
So make sure that you actually
set this configuration
inside of your Gradle file,
so that you don't end up
actually bloating images
that you've already
taken the time to compress.
Now, probably one of the
biggest things that you can do,
though, in terms of file
savings, is actually
consider replacing
your PNGs altogether
with vector drawables instead.
Now, for those who don't know,
PNG files are raster files.
They have a big problem in
that you need multiple of them
in a file to actually
get your images.
So we need one at
this resolution,
and one at this resolution,
and one at this resolution.
Which means, in our
APK, we're actually
ending up at a 55k footprint to
represent the same visual image
at different resolutions.
And there's some tricks
you can play here
with split APKs, and upsampling,
and all this other stuff,
but this is the
gist of the problem.
There's another way to
approach this issue,
and it's the concept of actually
drawing your images with code.
So that same
picture-- what if we
took a stab at it saying this.
Let's admit a byte
code that actually
draws a white
background, and then
another code that actually
draws a red circle.
Now, if we create our custom
DSL language and whatnot,
we could actually get this
into one byte per instruction
and actually end up
at about 15 bytes
to represent the same thing.
The result of this is that we
can generate those same three
images at any of
these three sizes,
using only 15 bytes
of our scheme,
instead of the 55k that
we were using before.
This is the concept of
vector image formats.
Right?
Basically, we take
some sort of stream
that represents how to draw
primitives on a screen,
we actually execute those,
rasterizing those primitives
to a bitmap in CPU memory.
We upload that to
the GPU, and then we
end up actually drawing
that to the screen.
The benefit you get here
is much smaller file sizes.
The downside, though, is
you actually trade off time.
It takes longer to
rasterize these images
and get them into memory
than it does to actually,
say, use the hardware
decoder and decode a JPEG.
So there's a little
bit of a trade-off
you have to deal with there.
But this is the whole
idea behind the Android's,
vector drawable format.
It's a series of
instructions that
define how to draw paths,
and colors, and gradients,
and all other sorts
of stuff, so that you
can draw these images at the
sizes you need on demand.
But the question is-- OK,
this is fine, this is fancy,
I've already got a
pipeline of awesome PNGs
and my artists know
how to make PNGs.
They don't know how to do
this vector drawable thing.
Come on, bald guy, let's
get to the point here.
What's really going on?
Don't worry.
So I decided to run a test.
How much could vector
drawables actually save me
as a developer?
To figure this out,
though, I needed
to take the I/O
sched application
and actually convert all of
my images to vector drawables.
Well, there's 270
of those things,
totaling up to 926k in size.
I don't have the time to
hand customize all 270
of those images.
Thankfully, there's
a tool to the rescue.
There's a great tool on the
internet called Potrace.
And this tool's been
around a long time.
It'll take a bitmap
image, which is literally
a image with 1-bit per
pixel, and actually
turn it into a vector format--
raster image to vector format.
So I decided to run this on
every asset inside the I/O
sched application.
And the results were
actually a lot better
than I expected, to be
honest with you, right?
So you can see the top
row here is the source.
And the bottom row
here is the result
of the Potrace application.
We're pretty close.
The first one looks identical.
The second one, you
can see some rounding.
The third one, pretty good.
The fourth one, you can see that
we're only dealing with shapes,
so we lose some color there.
And the hexagon is perfect.
The hexagon is actually a
really cool example here,
because that hexagon actually
absorbed 6k of our file size
at different resolutions.
However, the vector
version was only 961 bytes.
So even just running it
through here, we saw some wins.
The downside, though, is that
this is an automated tool.
Right?
I mean, this is only a test.
We're just trying
to figure out how
all this stuff works together.
And obviously, there
were some failures.
We missed some
interspersion detail.
Obviously, we're not getting
the exact font representation.
And it just fell over and
died on the I/O algorithm.
Right?
The result, though, I
think, was a good test
to figure out what
you could save.
So running things
through Potrace,
we actually ended up
with only 153 files,
because we didn't have to
have one for each resolution.
And the result
was actually 149k.
That's 84% reduction
in asset sizes,
by just moving everything to
be a vector drawable, which
is a pretty good savings.
Yes.
Let's clap.
[APPLAUSE]
This man.
Yes.
You started the clap, sir.
You are awesome.
Fantastic.
Yeah.
So 84% smaller, that's a
pretty good deal, right?
Now, it's worth noting
this was just a test.
You can't just go run Potrace
and convert everything over.
I mean, it spits out EPS
files, and that's not the same
as VD files.
And oh, by the way,
there's actually a chance
that you could
optimize stuff further.
Instead of just importing from
SVG, if you did stuff by hand,
you may actually be
able to get stuff
down even smaller than that.
But the main point is, you
can get a lot of savings
here by moving to
vector drawables,
so make sure you
take a look at it.
Now, let's talk about the big
images, the big, big images,
JPEGs.
Who loves JPEGs?
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah?
Yep.
I didn't hear
anybody in the back.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHS] I love the
begrudging pause.
Right?
Like, ugh.
Fine.
We're just here to stay
out of the heat. [LAUGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
Pass me some water.
This is great.
OK, JPEG files--
I've got to tell you,
JPEGS are-- they're crazy.
One of the most impressive
algorithmic systems I've
ever encountered.
It's impressive the math
that goes into this, not just
from an algorithm
perspective, but just
the raw math of the situation.
Take a look at this.
So when you encode a JPEG,
here's what's going on.
You take your source RGB image.
And the first thing that happens
is we actually convert it
to a separate color space.
The reason for this
is the human eye,
the psycho-visual
differences in the human eye
are less susceptible
to the YCBCR color
space, or the chroma
luminance color space.
Right?
We're actually more tuned--
the human eye is more tuned
to see differences in
RGBs, than we are YCBCR,
so the first thing the JPEG does
is convert it to that space.
The next thing is
we actually reduce
the size of the CB, the chroma
channels, CB and CR channels.
Again, the human
eye doesn't notice
as much changes
in that spectrum,
so it doesn't worry about it.
After that, we actually go
through and block up our image
and apply the discrete
cosine transform.
This is magical.
If you get a chance to check
out the blog post on this,
basically, the idea of the
discrete cosine transform
is that any signal
can be represented
by a sum of cosines.
What?
It's a thing.
Like these mathematicians
sat down and worked that out
on paper, before
computers were awesome.
Like, discrete
cosine transform is
one of the most amazing
things I have ever seen.
Basically, they can represent
any 8 x 8 block of pixels
by summing cosine transforms
across a 2D space.
That is awesome, right?
The output of that is then
ran into a quantization phase.
The quantization phase
just basically takes
the output of the
basis coefficients
and quantizes them down
to integers in a subspace
that we can actually
encode more.
Then it gets sent out to
this statistical encoding
phase, which may be
Huffman, or arithmetic,
or whatever your particular
flavor of the month is.
And then finally, of course,
we go to the output JPEG file.
Now, here's the weird thing.
This is awesome.
This is totally crazy, right?
Way harder than PNG.
Then why, when you
export an image,
you're given like one slider?
[LAUGHTER]
All of this chaos is
hidden behind one slider
when you export an image.
That's impressive
on its own right.
Now, the question is,
what should this value be?
This is the JPEG quality.
When you export a
JPEG, we ask you
what quality you want
it outputted at, right?
So the question is,
what should this be?
Right?
So let's take a visual look at
what Photoshop would actually
output as.
So here's PS12, so this it
would be 100% JPEG quality.
Right?
263k.
Let's drop down to
11, 10, go to 8.
You can start seeing
some blocking here.
Look right above the
red parrot's head.
You can start seeing
some ringing artifacts.
The gradients in the background
aren't as solid there.
Let's go down to 4.
So this is quality 4.
You see a lot more
ringing artifacts here.
Right?
You can start seeing the
quantization artifacts
in each 8 x 8 block, right?
And zero.
Obviously, some color
bleeding going on.
We're seeing some
big stuff there.
So the question is, though,
what value should I choose?
Right?
I mean, you can't open
every single image
and take a look at it and
choose the right value.
There's just no way
we can support that
in any sort of real pipeline.
The solution is to not, it's
to automate the whole process.
And for that-- I'll get
to it in another slide.
[LAUGHS] The real solution here
is to automate this process
and figure it out.
But that's actually not
what most people are doing.
What most people are
actually doing here,
is choosing some value and
exporting all of their images
at that.
The ImgMin project,
which is an open source
project on the internet, started
downloading a bunch of images
from all of these
social networks
and figuring out what their
exported quality was, and then
put it together in a table.
So you can actually see what
everyone is exporting things
at.
Now, the ones with ranges are
actually really impressive,
because it means that they're
trying to actually find
the right range of things.
The weird thing is it's not
as scalable as you'd think.
Right?
Like if something
happens to be brighter,
it's given these values.
If it's darker,
it's these values.
It's a little bit more
quantized than dynamic.
But the question
for your project
is, how do we figure
this out algorithmically?
And for that, I want to
introduce Butteraugli.
This is an open source project
made by the compression
team in Zurich who
loves naming things so
that I can't Google for them.
[LAUGHTER]
--or spell them
or pronounce them.
So to make sure that you
all can pronounce it,
we're going to say
it together here, OK?
This is going to be boo--
AUDIENCE: Boo--
COLT MCANLIS: Ter--
AUDIENCE: Ter--
COLT MCANLIS: Aug--
AUDIENCE: Aug--
COLT MCANLIS: Lee--
AUDIENCE: Lee.
COLT MCANLIS: Butteraugli.
AUDIENCE: Butteraugli.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
Now, you all can
Google this later.
In the native language,
it means a sweet bread
to eat with coffee.
But in the GitHub
project, it means a way
to compare the psycho-visual
similarity of two images.
This is basically a
way for us to say,
let me take a source
image and compress it
and see how the human eye
responds to the differences
between these two.
How much error can
we actually notice?
Now, you may have heard some
other terms in the past,
like PSNR.
Anybody hear that one?
Yeah?
SSIM?
These are common.
Yeah?
Nice.
These are very common things.
Think of Butteraugli in
the same fashion of that,
the ability to measure two
different psycho-visual changes
as an image changes.
Now, the real use
of Butteraugli,
the intention that
it was made for,
was to actually
figure out how much we
can compress an image before
the human eye notices anything.
Right?
How far can we go before
even the smallest perceived
visual change occurs?
And when you actually use
the Butteraugli library,
you'll notice that that actually
occurs at the 1.0 level.
So when you export
at Butteraugli 1.0,
that is where-- or
when you test it
and you get 1.0, that is
where the human eye starts
to notice artifacts.
Anything above
1.0 is chaos land.
Anything below 1.0, the
human eye can't decipher.
Right?
So your goal would
be like, hey, we
have a lot of high res images.
We want high res images, and we
want to find the ideal export.
This will help you.
But sometimes, I
don't want perfection.
Right?
Sometimes, I want a little
bit of compression artifacts
in there.
Sometimes, someone's loading
something on a 2G network,
or they're sitting on
roaming, or they're
in the middle of India and
they don't have the right
connectivity, I want to give
them a worse quality image,
so it doesn't take them six
hours to download the thing.
Right?
They don't have to pay for it.
So maybe I'm OK going above 1.0.
So how would we go about
doing something like this?
How would we find the right
level for some other statistic?
And it's actually pretty easy.
If we actually take a little
Python script here and run
ImageMagick, we can convert
a PNG to a JPEG file
at some quality.
Right?
We convert that
JPEG back to a PNG,
so we know we're
actually comparing apples
to apples here.
And then we run those two PNG
files through Butteraugli.
And if the score is
above some random metric
that we've decided, based
upon artificial intelligence
and machine learning for
this person, in this area,
on this device-- let's
just say it's 2.0,
randomly-- then we return
that quality value.
So what does this look like?
So I ran this on
the parrots images.
And you can see,
really quickly, we
found that, about quality 60,
we passed the 2.0 threshold.
Right?
And then, it actually was able
to dive in a little bit more
and get single-step
quantization.
Actually found that, at quality
62, we broke the 2.0 threshold.
Let's look at this side by side.
This is the 1.0 score
and the 2.0 score.
The difference is 60k.
Right?
But the Butteraugli
image metric is so nice
that you can see very small
changes in the 2.0 version.
Of course, this is blown up on a
screen, and on the live stream,
and all this other stuff.
But the main point that
I'm trying to get to here
is that you don't have to
choose one image compression
quality for everything.
You can actually dynamically
choose this and move on.
So beyond that, though,
there's a couple of things
that you can do by hand.
JPEG, unfortunately, has the
same problem that PNG does.
Right?
File, Save As from
Photoshop, 11k
for that 16 x 16 pixel block.
11k!
Ugh!
Are you sure your designers
aren't doing that?
[LAUGHTER]
Are you really sure?
Think about it.
Maybe send a text real quick.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah?
Save As gets us to 1.1k.
Still, that's a 16
pixel x 16 pixel image.
The funny thing is-- you want
to know what's going on here?
Extra data, Metadata.
JPEGs and PNGs have the
ability to add block data
to your image.
So when I'm standing
on the Google campus,
wandering around,
because it's Google I/O,
and I take a picture
of the Gator.
This is how my image
sharing service
knows where I was standing.
There's blocks that
they can insert
into your JPEG files that
have this location-based
information.
And that bloats your image.
And if you're not properly
removing this stuff,
as an image serving
application, that
means every other user who's
downloading it is grabbing
this extra bloated data.
Obviously, that's
not a good idea.
So let's talk about-- that's
obviously block removal,
but there's a bunch
of other places
that we can optimize
here, right?
We can change how
we're downsampling.
We can improve the way that the
DCT coefficients are handled.
We can improve the
way we quantize.
Or we could just apply a
better statistical encoder.
Right?
Great news, folks.
You don't got to worry
about any of that.
Everybody's already
got it solved.
Googling for this brings
you a pretty good handful
of algorithms and tools
that you can put right
into your tool chain.
The first two here,
JPEGMini and MozJPEG,
actually go to find another
lossy compression variant.
So they'll degrade
the image quality
of your image to get you
just a little bit farther
and a little bit more savings.
Right?
On the other two, cJPEG
and packJPG are lossless.
They're going to try to
improve those quantization
and statistical encoding stages,
so that you don't actually
lose any bits.
The interesting thing is that
packJPG actually works more
as a post format than anything.
It'll actually take
your JPEG and encode it
in its own format, so we can
get it even smaller than that.
And of course, you've got
a lot of web solutions
that you can find
too where you upload
your image to some
API or some service,
it'll do everything on the
back end and send it to you.
I don't care what you use.
Pick one, right?
And don't let your designers
hit Save As from Photoshop.
Right?
Any of these will work.
Pick one.
Test it out.
See how it works.
Send me a tweet, let me
know how it happened.
Right?
One thing, though.
I've got to say, this one's
really cool to do by hand.
And I've only got
a couple minutes,
so I'm going to try to
go through this fast.
Two images here, top
one 175, Colt-modified,
82k on the bottom.
What we're doing here-- remember
that the first thing that JPEG
does is split your image
into a different color space,
because the human eye is
more perceptible to some loss
than others.
So what we do here is, we
actually, in Photoshop, split
this to LAB color mode.
Right?
Which is luminance
and then AB channels.
We select the areas of high
contrast inside of the AB
channels, and we actually
just go File Blur.
What we're doing here
is we're actually
reducing the number of unique
colors, the amount of noise
in these chroma channels, so
that when the JPEG codec comes
back through, there's
less information there
that it has to find unique.
And you're actually going to get
better compression as a result.
So this simple
technique, going through,
hand optimizing
some of this stuff,
can actually save
you-- what was this?
2x or 50% savings on a file?
If you're serving a million
files a day, that's huge.
Right?
All right.
Let's get to the
final one here-- WebP.
Fans of WebP?
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah?
Yes.
WebP, I've got to say,
as impressive as JPEG
is, WebP is in its own league.
I've done compression
for a long time.
It's in its own league.
I mean, on one side, you've
got a whole suite of algorithms
that applies, so we can
keep up with the lossy type
of compression that JPEG does.
On the other side
of it, it's got
this whole separate filtering
and prediction policy,
so it can do lossless
encoding, just like PNG.
It's even got some LZ77 and
dictionary encoding in there,
so it can do that.
The result is pretty simple.
Across the board, all of these
optimizations and techniques
make it competitive with
both PNG and JPEG everywhere.
And it supports all of
these features, as well.
And in most time,
it's actually winning,
if you check out those.
So you get smaller file sizes.
You get more features
in those file sizes.
And it's supported natively
on Android, which is awesome.
Round of applause
for that, right?
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Now, let's get
real for a minute.
I know we laughed at gummy
bears and had a clapping war,
but let's get real.
Can we get real?
Round of applause
for getting real.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah?
The weirdest applause
request ever.
If there's one thing you
remember-- some bald guy got
on stage at Google
I/O. I was hiding
in a tent trying to
get out of the sun,
and he yelled at me for an hour,
but I remembered one thing.
It's this.
This is one thing.
This is all I'm asking
you to remember.
That's it.
Nothing else, just this, OK?
This diagram.
When you're choosing what
kind of image to make,
the decision on the
format is super important.
The first thing you
have to ask yourself
is, can this image
be a vector drawable?
If yes, make it a
vector drawable.
Done.
Easy.
Go to lunch.
If no, ask yourself,
do I support WebP?
If yes, make it a WebP.
Go to lunch.
You're done for the day.
Good job.
Peer bonus.
Sweet.
If you don't support
WebP, ask yourself,
does it need transparency?
If yes, obviously, you've
got to use PNG for that.
If no, you've got
to ask yourself,
is it simple or complex?
Remember, PNG optimizes
and compresses better
in areas of very
self-similar pixels.
So the more photo-realistic
an image, the worse
PNG is going to compress it.
The more simpler an
image, the better PNG's
going to compress it, right?
If it's complex, we're
going to go JPEG.
Now, if we end up
at PNG, we want
to make sure that we're
running a tool on it, reducing
colors, trying to
make it indexed,
and hand-optimizing it in
places where we need to
for Hero assets.
Same thing with JPEG.
Use a tool, correct the
quality, and hand optimize
where you can.
I love that everyone's
taking pictures.
This is live streamed.
You can get this later.
[LAUGHTER]
In fact, if you check out
the Spaces application,
I'll put this up later.
Put your phones
down, you're good.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm flattered that you're
taking a picture of me,
but you know-- I can pose.
Anyone want a
picture of the pose?
[LAUGHTER]
No?
Anybody?
Oh, Someone there.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: There.
There.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh,
need to be over here?
[LAUGHTER]
OK, no.
We've got to get back.
We've got to get back to it.
The A/V people are
getting mad at me.
Sorry.
OK.
Most importantly, though,
this one simple thing,
profile your code.
Profile your code.
Before you make any decisions,
before you make any performance
changes, before you
change your format,
before you put bits on the
wire that your users are
going to have to pay to
download, profile it.
Make a decision based
upon evidence, and data,
and the best thing
for your users.
Do not go lazily
into these decisions,
because they have
huge ramifications
for the people who love
you and your applications.
Profile it.
In some cases, JPEG's going
to be better than PNG.
In some cases, WebP's going
to be the best option.
In some cases, it's
going to load too slow,
and you're going to
want to use a JPEG.
In every single situation,
profile your code.
Find the sweet spot.
Optimize for your
users, in every case.
And thank you, thank
you, thank you, so much,
for coming to this session.
My name's Colt McAnlis.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]